chissà rimasto oggi giocheremo con la
fiducia di baldi 18 sempre al piano che
baldi possa avere una fidanzata bar a
quanto pare questa è la fidanzata di
base e anche lo stadio righello anche la
faccio inquietante come baldini e lo
stesso è un insegnante come baldi
materia insegna non lo so lo scopriremo
assieme però sapete che baldi un
insegnante di matematica
so comunque il nome ani tron oa litro
che famiglia al mio nome la cosa non mi
piace ma comunque vedremo assieme che
cosa succederà da quello che ho capito
siamo stati rinchiusi nella sua scuola o
siamo tipo in punizione vedremo se
riusciamo a scappare ma voi ovviamente
come sempre lasciato un bambino
provate essere mi piace entro quattro
secondi
432 grotte o scaduto a prendere i bob
carr mettetevi comodi iniziamo eccola
c'è scritto alla lavagna che brutta
allora meglio se scritto non disturberò
miss anita patron e su una ruota è visto
sia una specie di robot ok cosa dobbiamo
fare dobbiamo provare a bissare l'oro
dobbiamo aprire qui eccolo questo
vediamo
quanti maturi l'allarme l'acqua non
cattivo l'esisto si sta rompendo
arrabbiando ma
anche perché io sono già scappato
lontano
questo è stato il buio perché perché
adesso lei arriverà abbiamo tre minuti
non aiutano tv 26 noi stessi ciao
no no che ha preso bene siamo
sopravvissuti
dove sei tu non voglio io sono tutto ok
andiamo assieme
allora proviamo qua anche se prima mi ha
preso qui
e qui scappa scappa questa si apre a
cosa dobbiamo giocare non capita solo
dietro dibatto giocato mettono tutti che
te devo dì da anni sta inseguendo noi
aiuto
conviene andare da questa parte no sta
continuando a inseguirmi come
aiuto no no no mai via
ok cambiamo strada dobbiamo provare
tutte le porte
dove è lì lì visto il secondo te no al
chiodo
proviamo a seguire gli altri giocatori
vediamo forse loro sanno meglio dove
andare
sono tutti scappati
non lo so io sto seguendo questo altro
giocatore forse sta proprio facendo eco
trovato una presa
bisogna andare tutto in fondo poi c'è
una freccia qua per scappare in questo
senso la prontissima ho seguito sono un
giocatore ecco perché ci sono riusciti
almeno sono lontana da quel ei
nel frattempo che vitali si raggiunge io
scappo il più palacio smetto posti
pierobon ritrovo speriamo alla fine di
riuscire a
distruggerla in qualche modo e come tale
o
per fortuna siamo lontani da quel robot
vista che ha piazzato varie trappole per
noi guardavamo
si sono vari spuntoni
non ci credo
per fortuna non è accaduto
ho capito aspettano salito prima io
perché dopo un po cadono queste vedi ok
quindi bisogna andare veloci se n'è
fatta di piatti finito la prova guarda
poi ci vuole spiaccicare è che il re è
molto attenti
no
beh per fortuna lei non è qua adesso
altrimenti sarebbero ad ora più
difficile che saliamo ok allora qui ci
sono delle ventole è
fissato questo mandato
no
ok navate l'ho fatta andiamo dove sei
nel campo di basket ferma siamo dentro
la scuola che bello era cosa per
vorrebbero condonata brava mamma mi ha
fatto inquietante ha preso
ok allora attento perché esce dalla
porta mi ha preso
troppo paura quando esce dalle porte
questi prende bobba
forse sì se ci sono quasi sono dettagli
qualcosa come tarraga per favore bravo a
diventare michele entra nella nel tubo
nato molto
bravo
ok che anzi a questa allora ci sia di
male bisogna stare attenti qua bisogna
saltare su tutto ma non
si interrompe a di visto saltare
anch'io e ora a sui tubi attento lo
cadranno giu sembra botto in alto
ma spero che le loro timori mi
improvviso
turbinosa
ok ti aspetto quali sono quale c'è una
scritta nel pavimento in cui c'è scritto
stai attento alla papera papa per e
forse mi ritrovai degli degli haqqani
entourage arrivato quindi dobbiamo
andare di qua sono sceso giù c'è
qualcosa no cioè almeno fino al momento
non vedo che anche ansia
non mi ha preso ancora perché era così
brutta mi corre gli animatronics di
fight nei brero forse sono degli
animatronics anche loro eh sì forse tu
io qua sto provando cercata dappertutto
ma non c'è nulla no la povera dietro di
me ma perchè devi festa cercate di
mettervi sta cercando di mangiarmi aiuto
verde brutta dovevo trovare la strada
non riesco a trovarle riesco a trovare
papà
basta patamia tanti fan che vanta ecco
lo sono stato trovato la strada
su un muro un muro c'è un buco su mac è
pieno di paure come faccio a trovarlo
sono fa breccia ci sono le frecce non
vedo nessuna presa per abbattere via
buffa ma chi ce l'aveva proprio qui
salta salta
visto essere riuscito però a ok ragazzi
ho abbassato il volume perché io mi
spaventa davvero tanti temi questi
giochi in questioni jones che se non si
fosse capito ma spavento davvero troppo
provo
io non mi ricordo come quella cosa le
muro forse
no ma questa papera mostruosa iniziato
mai forse ci sei quasi
eccola preparati
sia diventato sordo da questa parte nel
frattempo
c'è allora sentito rumori e 9 quando
salvi tieni gli occhi aperti
con gli spuntoni
ma insomma queste forme di pane bianco
rieti poleschi prum avete visto le
scritte dell'uomo sirena il padre di
grammy e si può quella che ti fa
spaventare tanti che mi ha sempre preso
sei fatta io credo che è vitale mi ha
superato molto io sono un bravo
sbrigate dovere l'altro ok c'è ancora
uno brava notte ha preso la
brava e allora succede qua dobbiamo
spingere bene questa porta e passare
ci sono dei laser
l'importante che non si siano con gli
arriva tronic scritto qualcosa nel muro
guarda c'è scritto vattene via hanno
mentito karam il suo sole mi dispiace
non riusciremo mai a sopravvivere
no devi dire che già mi fai troppo pure
l'amore no no non credo e allora che
cosa c'è o no vieni ci sono solo delle
trappole e siamo nella scuola di notte
un altro mi riguarda non sentiamo di qua
sembra facile dai basta solo stare
attenti a passare in mezzo a queste
trappole c'è scritto classe lezione d
arte
chi ci sarà come te o poverina o che ci
sarà come insegnante quale ragione
non so molto
dove c'è scritto dobbiamo stare attenti
ai manichini
sapete quel gol preso lì sono quelli che
insomma che si usano per disegnare hanno
preso vita si fa paura ma allo stesso
tempo è interessante inquietante perché
sapere che adoro le cose inquietanti e
bombay visto di notte sono fermi un
inseguimento facendo arriviamo
forse son passato
possiamo nella stanza rossa per le
fotografie
dimmi che siamo riusciti a scappare
piove forse siamo vicini all'uscita
sveliamo e ma da che parte a dobbiamo
stare un'alta sollecito
qualcuno quando non vetro
un successo che è successo quando come
perché taglia mi spaventa davvero ridere
mila parti no poverina click le mani
come quei tanti che si si si pensavo che
fossimo riusciti a scappare dalla peste
nuovo dobbiamo scendere di una continua
trento arti metteranno di nuovo del
frascone nella caffetteria
hanno tanti banchi
ok se si aspetta sente un rumore da
galilei lamierino vedi che cos'è non lo
so mostra scelto di forma ti apprezzo la
foto pezzi
allontanati
forse qua forse quella via d'uscita
c'è caso che con animatronics chef fatto
a forma di come si chiama quell'operaio
minor impatto appare lo stand matterello
avere paura di mattarello per mezzo per
rivaldo attendono soprattutto quella
strada era una trappola bisogna andare
nell'altra strada cioè tutto dritto
perché va questi rumori e un mattarello
spero sia questa
forse saltare è meglio se salti e meglio
ma dove bisogna dare ho capito forse
dove c'è un buco qua bisogna terra ma
ci aspettiamo vitale c'è scritto che
dobbiamo dare
noi
siamo sotto anche figo non hanno mai
fatto un escape from cui bisognava
votare soltanto così che bello non mi
dire che un labirinto questi stanno
tornando indietro penso di sì che sia un
labirinto sotto ma questo che nasce da
ragioni forse dobbiamo risalire qua
adesso adc buona idea una piscina
sono pochissime della scuola casa per
riuscire a sé il trampolino certo di
notte un po inquinata però è anche
affascinante norma successo mi si apre
qua forse questa porta
aveva
attentati anidro knicks vai sul bus c'è
scritto dai sbrigati che sta arrivando a
salire sul bus forse ce lo abbiamo fatto
davvero
tutte le russe
non mi dire che una trappola mi metto in
ritardo eccolo o no
ma come tutte e due non è quel bus metro
ma c'è anche lo chef attenzione no sono
tutti artisti possibile
uccidere
il cane è riuscito andare subito noto
ricaricare recano dall'altra parte sono
le porte aiuto solo tu sei classico
santis in italy che lo stanno entrando
nel bus o poi parte guarda
sara ciao ciao coperte
io non vorrei dire però il bus stava
andando da quando sono salito è quindi è
iniettato il mezzo abbiamo vinto sito de
il vecchio e fa poco ti esce qui ecco su
ruote basse per tenerlo sempre rivolta
offerta è troppo per narrare poi torna
indietro
non ci sarà niente beh cela sotto i
[Musica]
19 è stata super divertente che schifo
ma anche sarò molto molto buono capitan
deve dimostare porto un altro nascosto
poi c'è una freccia 10 ad andare in
questa porta dove so se è una cosa
giusta però non è superata proviamo dai
unicamente nella porta vediamo che
succede
che è ma allora la porta apre un altro
giovane come stato super divertente la
sua donna mi piace se volete un'altra
eprom paura adesso facciamo quale oltre
a castellina cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite buona visione ciao